&gt;&gt; And welcome back. While we were away we actually had to sensley take home the
the Golden Brain for detecting a difference of under 2%.
&gt;&gt; That's amazing, I guess that you were proved wrong, but your human difference
threshold average of 3%.
&gt;&gt; Well, Andy, that is why they call it an average.
&gt;&gt; Well, either way, it's pretty amazing and even more importantly I'm okay and my
bleeding has stopped.
&gt;&gt; Andy, it was a paper cut.
&gt;&gt; Lauren, it hurt.
&gt;&gt; Well, I'm glad you're feeling better.
&gt;&gt; Thanks, but this bandaid actually feels a little weird.
&gt;&gt; How so?
&gt;&gt; Well, I don't know. There's all these little groves in it, and they're kind of
bothering me.
&gt;&gt; Hmm. That's your mechanoreceptors sensing that.
&gt;&gt; Wait. My what?
&gt;&gt; Your mechanoreceptors. They're little neurons in your skin that are sensitive
to different things, like grooves or texture, shape, even vibrations and
motion.
&gt;&gt; And each one is sensitive to its own specific sort of texture? &gt;&gt; Yeah.
&gt;&gt; That's really fascniating. It's almost like the rods and cones in our eyes,
which we use to.
&gt;&gt; Andy, I'm going to stop you there, I just gt word from Susan that they're
going to start the brain ceremony. We'll get back to that in a minute.